hey everybody welcome to lab coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today I have a new
webcam and I also have sunglasses on so
you might be able to see in the
reflection the webcam is really bright
it's so bright that I was thinking about
wearing sunglasses it's super bright but
the lights are nice they have the lights
off in my office but my face is lit up
before the only lighting that I had was
a small lamp that didn't really do
anything and then on my other screens
that you can't see when I'm streaming I
tried to make them be white so I'd use
like the white theme on YouTube and try
to put basically just windows like
Chrome windows with all white
backgrounds all around my main screen so
this should be a much better solution
than just trying to use my monitors
although I'll probably end up taking the
sunglasses off because they they do help
with the brightness but I can't really
read my code that well it's too dark but
I haven't streamed for a while I had
pretty crazy end of the week last week
as some kind of like emergency things
that needed to needed to be fixed so I
had basically my boss and his boss had
to do a presentation to a bunch of
members of the board here on Saturday
and so I had to type something up for
them and make sure that there was a
fully functional demo site so I got all
that working and I also added a proper
URL and SSL certificate to a WordPress
installation so if you have the code
locally on your machine definitely do do
a git pull get the latest well if you
have a fork that
do what you need to do to get the to
update your fork and then make sure it
has the new URL because it may not work
to grab data from the old IP address and
the reason I needed to do that is
because I was running the demo site with
an SSL certificate when it tried to grab
the data from the IP address which of
course was just HTTP it couldn't get
that data without an error popping up
the hey you're trying to load you know
HTTP data on an HTTPS so took way longer
to get that all set up than I thought
but it's all running now and today we
are going to create a scroll spy
component I had a nice meeting earlier
today with one of the students who is
working on one section of this site and
it would benefit them if they had a
scroll sky scroll spy component so we're
gonna make the basic functionality for
them and they can adjust it as needed
also they were just offered a job which
is really awesome so he's gonna graduate
in May and already has a job lined up so
that was pretty cool and helping out on
this project helped him to to get the
job because although the job doesn't
deal directly with front-end development
they were really interested in the fact
that he knew about JavaScript because
that's something that they need I guess
they needed more people that knew about
that so it may be something they add on
to his job after he started so I thought
that was kind of cool that somewhat like
indirectly you know that this project
kind of helped him out and getting a job
so that was really cool let me think it
looks like we have a decent amount of
people I'm gonna take off the shades for
now so I'm gonna try to get started I
don't think there's anything else to
update you all on in terms of you know
things that have happened in the site
there's one weird thing going on with my
tests my unit tests were failing so I
messed around a little bit with it and
now for some reason the index tests the
snapshot is huge like we're talking like
over 50 megabytes huge so I messed
something up so I may just end up
removing the the test for the index page
for now because it's taking forever to
load and then just trying to figure out
what was wrong with it you know sometime
later so if you're having trouble with
the test it's something I did I don't I
don't know and let's see yeah so let's
get into it I should probably start up
and grok before we start
so some of you may remember that I was
having some issues with the built-in
camera so hopefully I will not have the
same issues with this other webcam for
some of you were asking why I had the
sunglasses on it's because my new webcam
has a really bright like ring light
around it so I can't remember who it was
but somebody recommended to me to get
the the Razer
keo webcam and I did get that and so far
I really like it the quality is
definitely better than the one that's
built into an iMac or MacBook Pro and
the fact that it has the built-in light
is really nice for me because I'm always
coding in the dark so I didn't really
want to invest in an extra lighting and
I'm not really sure how the best way to
set that up anyway so this is simple I
mean obviously it's not like you're the
best you can get but you know really
it's not it doesn't really make sense
for me to invest in all this equipment
you know I'm just kind of doing this on
the side I don't get any money for this
so wouldn't necessarily be the the
smartest investment our world says the
only thing is that the audio is out of
sync okay I'm gonna have to look into
how to fix that then let me
all right so I just did a google search
on that and that way when the streams
over I will remember that and I'll check
out that the search results yes I don't
really want I don't want that to happen
all the time I'm gonna try to fix that
because I know it can be annoying when
it's out of sync whenever I took put the
code up on the screen it you know you
probably won't be looking at my face
anymore so it won't be as big of a deal
let's see so I'm switching now and let's
go over let's start this Pomodoro timer
and someone to do one Pomodoro session
and then we're going to take a break and
we'll do some answer some questions and
live chat and then I'll go back and do
another Pomodoro session we'll see how
much we can get done probably two
Pomodoro sessions is you know all I'm
going to do today you know at that point
we'll probably be getting close to 6:00
p.m. my time and then that's definitely
time for me to get home and and help get
the kids ready for bed all right so
first thing I'm gonna do yeah let me
just get rid of this index unit test for
now just delete that and then I'll get
rid of this snapshot since I don't
really have time to figure out why
that's that's not working properly so
and I don't want it to take to mess up
our our process of testing and just take
forever so we're just going to get rid
of that for now and we need to grab let
me go over here on my other screen so
that we can get some code
I know we've done something like this
before let's check out I'm gonna pull
this over on the other screen as soon as
I get it
get it working alright let's fill this
over so just when you ought to have a
visual of what this is gonna look like
it's going to be really simple just a
little menu on the side which I assume
that is gonna you know have a position
fixed and as we scroll down the page it
highlights the area that you are in the
page and if we wanted to just skip to an
area just press the button and it skips
to the area okay so that's what to do
this one's a little bit buggy actually
like it's not exactly
we may have to improve upon that cuz
this is not working exactly right so but
this is basically how it's gonna look
and I need to find the github repo for
this as well so let me pull this over
and oh yeah resource center yeah that
was it
let's go into our source and our views
and planning guide and we'll figure out
what we called this I don't think we put
this in a separate component so did we
okay yeah it looks like we're tracking
scroll position and everything in here
okay but then we do have this planning
guidelines component all right so that
makes sense so I guess the first thing
we'll do is add will we need to to the
actual page and then we'll check out
what's here in our planning guidelines
component that we'll need to bring in
and use to create our own component so
I'm gonna move this off to my other
screen so I can can look at it and then
we're gonna go in here to the mission
CAS page so the the student who's who's
been working with me so basically
they're doing like an internship with
with me and then they're also working
with another department on a project and
so we have at this university a whole
department dedicated to missionary work
so like they go into places all over the
world like you know really really poor
areas and help with like to teach you
know kids and that orphanages and you
know feed the poor do a kind of stuff
like that on spring break which is
really kind of cool you know a lot of
people on spring break they go party
well our students go and you know they
they help the poor so it's definitely
it's good but right now on the website
the section for that isn't spectacular
so the the head of that department is
really nice guy
he's always wanted something nicer for
that and we really didn't have you know
the capability or the resources to do
that on the the old website
but on this website I think it's going
to look a lot nicer and so a group of
students has been working on on doing
that and they've been I've been kind of
collaborating and just you know checking
in and basically giving them like the
whole framework and like here's what
what you need to work with them and I
started them out on building the page
with just basic HTML CSS because that's
what they're comfortable with and I said
once you build it out and you like how
it looks then we can convert it into
react so that's where we're at right now
is converting that page into react so we
did some work on it this morning and I
think it's looking kind of nice so we
should be able to see yeah let me go to
that page so we can see what's happening
so we're at that local hosts 3,000 and
you all couldn't see this page to
missionary outreach so if you have that
and grok link that I pasted it in there
a little while ago and you type at the
end of it slash missionary - outreach
then you'll see this page and so I think
it's really you know not bad like this
student that has done this work is a
computer science student and doesn't
really have a whole lot of experience
with JavaScript and front-end
development at all so and just you know
just this semester has gone from
basically having zero experience with
react at all you know to being able to
build this out and I think it's it's
certain it's looking pretty good
I'm not sure about this header right
here let me know what you all think
about this so I I told him to leave it
in because I'm just not sure about it I
know it's it's like I didn't want to say
no automatically because it's a new
design element so I want to get over
that like shock of like hey I've never
seen that design element in this site
this particular site before and just
kind of give it a few days and look at
but I would like your opinion on what do
you think four sections having you know
this kind of thing instead of like a
fool you know across the page strip just
kind of a half you know I don't know I'm
not sure about it but I would definitely
like some some input on that but the
idea is that is that each one of these
these cards and he had a nice adaptation
of the cards that we were using on the
home page each one of these you'd be
able to click learn more and it would
have its own page that would have videos
from that particular trip pictures and
then kind of maybe like a story of what
happened on that trip and more
information yeah and then we'll have it
on the other end on the WordPress side
of things we're gonna make it really
easy for the people that work in that
department to edit that so all the
fields will be marked out so that if as
soon as they add a new post it'll
automatically appear in the right
section on this home page and it will
create its own its own page so that's
what we have so far I mean I can already
see a few things that maybe I would
adjust just little things font size you
know here and there
let me check route I see a few you are
bringing in are you're adding some some
opinions here so I'm gonna check it real
quick while we're lowering on this page
okay some some advice here on this this
side thing
Frankie's saying you know maybe it
should be centered swap swap Neal says
need more margin and maybe make it
bigger so it's more prominent
okay so Frank you saying make the the
tech center oh okay yeah I could see it
being bigger would be good all right
thank you I appreciate that that
feedback there so it'll probably get
adjusted a bit you know at least it
it'll get adjusted a bit my thought was
you know I just have text right there as
another header and it wouldn't it
wouldn't have any background or anything
but I do want to give this this a chance
all right
so what we want to do then on this page
is make that that side navigation and
it's going to be a little tricky right
because it's not as simple as what we
did on that last page that I showed you
we can't just put it right here it's
gonna look terrible right so we need you
know basically as we scroll down you
know at maybe it starts to appear here
so let's say it it scrolls with the page
until you get here and then we go to
position fixed and then it'll scroll
down with you and if you scroll back up
it would stop here and not go up any
higher I think I think that's what we
need you know we definitely need you we
definitely don't want it to be up here
so it's gonna have a little bit of
different functionality but first things
first let's just get some of the code
over and then we can adjust that as as
we need to so let's go in oops I've
already moved it over here
so look we're in this mission CAS page
and let's scroll down here we are so I
did um let's see get initial frost turn
I did say yes so I had some things in
here that I had commented out for for
the student that I'm working with just
say like here's here it is if you need
it right at some point we'll probably
will be pulling in data so that's why I
kind of wanted to leave this in here
even though we're not pulling in data
yet so let's bring in what we have from
this other component
okay so we have quite a bit and I'll
bring it in but then will will
definitely go need to go over it a bit
okay so this is what we have and we
definitely would need to bring in
throttle from lodash which we are we are
using elsewhere so we won't need to in
to bring in and this NPM package and
then right now we're not using this log
page you so let's get rid of this and
what's up with this why each is not
defined
I'm like thinking didn't did we do
something similar to this already
I guess we didn't I just have this
feeling like we've done this before
maybe I'm just thinking to the other
project
okay
all right so there's definitely some
things that we will need to change or at
least adjust since we have this here are
we not yeah okay so we don't most of our
markup is actually gonna live in this
component and not be in another
component so you can check out let me
give you the link to this github page
that I have on my other screen so you
all can see that as well if you click
the link that I just pasted it in and it
doesn't work try copying and pasting it
that'll usually work so I need to go to
a different component in this other repo
two planning guidelines and see what
we're doing here this process
scroll to
alright so in our component didn't mount
for the the other component in that
other repo that were were checking out
the Resource Center repo for the
planning guidelines ojs component we do
have something extra in component did
mount and we're bringing in a four slice
headers from gets out coordinates for
actually bringing quite a bit more than
I even realized thing I did
Wow this is way more complicated than I
imagined
I definitely didn't remember it being
this complicated probably it's because
one of you did most of the work for this
component and not me that's usually what
what it happens whenever I go back and
I'm like well I don't remember doing
that
okay so let's add this in once I get
everything on this page we'll go through
it more closely and see that what does
it do and what do we need to change but
for now
trying to find where that just bring
mission ships okay
I'm gonna do spring oops
[Music]
spring what was I thinking okay there we
go
ref you go spring and let's give it an
ID spring as well one minutes gonna use
of string literals and ref ass uses
deprecated okay
all right so we have it there let's just
give it let's throw in another one here
at the bottom I guess we don't need it
all the way at the bottom do we just put
it down here
put another one down here and let's just
call this summer just so that we have
another one for our menu so for right
now I'm okay with hard coding this
because there's only going to be four
sections and there's not like we're not
gonna add more seasons to the year right
it's gonna be spring summer or fall and
winter
otherwise I would
you'll probably be looping over things
and adding more we will do that
eventually but for now we you know that
we don't need to mess with that it's
just gonna add some complexity that we
don't really need right now okay so
since we're doing that we will be able
to get rid of a bit of this up here but
let's let me make sure I have everything
over here first also if you're asking
questions and you're wondering why I'm
not answering them I will answer
questions in just about two minutes I
like to break things up and do some code
and then go and do some questions you
know kind of back and forth all right so
I think I have almost everything we just
need this planning guide nav components
okay so I'm gonna bring in the markup
I'll bring this mark up in here and I'm
gonna put it down here where it'll
probably end up being on the page so
really we're gonna want this I guess
right here so some things that we're
gonna need to bring over some things
that we won't need I don't think we're
gonna need this or this and we're not
gonna be mapping over anything right now
I think we're going to hard-code this at
least while we're just getting it to
work we're gonna hard code it okay so
that's mostly everything that we need
there are probably some styles you know
living somewhere that we could bring
over as well but I think we have all our
functions and all our markup this is
actually not a bad place to stop we're
going to do a short break I'm gonna get
to some questions I'm gonna scroll all
the way up to the top and just work my
way down the live chat Matthew said nice
shades Jessie welcome to the Rockstar
coder Club yeah if you weren't here for
the beginning of the chat I had
sunglasses on so smilers asked where's
your beard yeah I shaved
no more beard my wife always hated the
beard so once it started to get warm it
was God hmm sorry about the yard I'm
pretty tired
I've been sick really the last week I've
been getting worse and I finally went to
the doctor yesterday and
- antibiotic and so hopefully I'll start
feeling better just so it doesn't matter
what I do if I have done matter how much
I sleep or if I work out or don't work
out I'm exhausted all the time
my Michael asked if I had a hangover
no no hangover oh I forgot to tell you
all earlier I was invited to speak at
career day for my son's third-grade
class so I did that today and it was
awesome
and I told the students I built websites
and they thought that was cool but as
soon as I told him how to YouTube show
they all got really excited and wanted
to know how many subscribers I had and
they wanted to subscribe to my channel
and so that was really fun and then I
told them that I made some like little
video games you know just just some
html5 games and they all wanted to know
about the games but they made me a card
if you could see the card so they made
me a nice card they all signed it and
they gave me some chocolate chip cookies
so those those are cool experience
sans car says I have a problem in
Android studio would you help me I've
actually never used Android studio so I
mean I'd love to help you but I don't
know that I'm gonna be able to help you
that much so if anybody else in the live
chat has used Android studio you know
maybe reach out to sans car and and
maybe figure out what's what's going on
Frankie says why does our sensei look
like an aviator pilot today cool that's
funny Kobe the sensei Dez desarrollo
says the scroll spy with react sounds
good
cool
Dennis s should I spend my time to learn
jQuery or react I would learn reacts I
mean it definitely depends like for your
current job do you need to know more
jQuery or react or are you just learning
and you could learn either one I would
learn react I think you're gonna find
more jobs and higher paying jobs knowing
reacts but there definitely are still a
lot of places that use jQuery so you can
there's work for both but I I think that
react is it's a little bit more
challenging but I have more fun with
react than I than I did with jQuery Juke
Jakarta I'm really sorry for
mispronouncing let me know how I should
pronounce it but anyway they say I think
we are in a situation where we have a
lot of framework framework and it's
going to be a little trouble about which
framework I have to choose to work with
which I just want to talk about react
nodejs and angular yeah I mean that's
definitely a big decision for a
developer like what framework am I gonna
use some don't really have a choice
because they have to use whatever their
boss says they have to use but if you do
have the choice it's gonna be a
difficult decision right you could try
to learn a little bit about all of them
or you could try to really become an
expert at one so that's you know that's
definitely a decision that needs to be
made at some point but if you keep
learning JavaScript just regular
JavaScript it'll be easier and easier to
switch into a framework at some point
so don't feel like you have to make that
decision too early if you're not sure
just you know keep learning and it's
once you learn a framework it's it's not
that hard to switch a lot of the
concepts are similar even if the
frameworks you know really different
just the ideas behind frameworks in
general can can transfer so you know
don't be too worried about it's not like
the end of the world if you pick one
framework and then switch a year later
or something but I mean that's it's a
legitimate choice you know but you know
don't stress too much about it just as
long as you're getting better with with
coding like you'll learn these skills
that help you pick up anything you know
more quickly okay let me I'm going to
write down where I have left off in the
chat and we're gonna do some more coding
so that's fine okay let me know what
y'all think about me streaming this late
I probably can't do this every day but
you know I'm always trying to figure out
what time of the day is the best to work
with everybody's time zones I know this
is like really late or really early in
the morning for those of you and in
India and in that time zone so this this
may not be the best and then for a lot
of you you know this is probably dinner
time you may be doing your commute home
I mean if that's the case you're not
even watching you know but if you're
gonna if you watch the recording in this
later so I do let me know how this works
out for you I mean we have about an
average amount of viewers maybe a little
less than we had the last couple streams
but so it seems like it is working out
but let's go we'll start this Pomodoro
session see how I've broken things
because we don't have this get top
coordinate and that should be in
where am I getting that from the of a
utils folder yeah
nope where's my components geek talk
coordinate okay
Wow
hmm
okay you know what let me bring over I'm
gonna create this component and we're
gonna import it so I kind of think this
should be in our utils falter and my
other project it was just in the regular
component folder but I think it makes
more sense here so let's make a new file
and let's call this gets top coordinator
J s and I'm gonna copy and paste
everything that we need okay so one
thing that we don't have right now is
lodash map values so and now I know for
sure that I didn't write this because I
usually don't pull in lodash stuff if
I'm gonna map value so I just use you
know dot map but I don't really want to
get into refactoring this right now so I
am gonna bring in lodash map values so
sorry I'm gonna do yarn add lodash and
it's not gonna be slash is it it's gonna
be let me look up I can't remember what
the
yes I'm gets dot
yes it'll be lodash dot map values and
actually is it all lowercase I think it
is
and then we will have to change missions
js2 bring in or get talk coordinate from
[Music]
so let's go you two okay
all right let's see that fixes our error
he is not defined or do we have this all
right so now it's just a matter of
figuring out all those things that I
brought in that aren't really there
really gonna work so let's check out
where I brought in key yep there we go
yeah and we don't need we don't need a
key right now cuz we aren't gonna be
mapping over this but I would like to
have more than one allies so let's
figure this out active section he and
active maybe we will need a key
[Music]
to figure out what we're naming this and
then we don't have title so instead of
title we're just gonna make right now
it'll be spring missions for now and
[Music]
class name like the section it was key
and active all I'm sorry was
alright I'm gonna have to go back and
see what I have going on
just planning guys nav before
okay so we were using before we were
making the key just a number so whatever
number it was so we were mapping over
this and we were just using like the
iterator is the key so I don't really
I'd rather not do that right now so
basically we were saying if the active
section which was being passed down I
guess from the state of the parent
component so if the active section
equaled key so equaled whatever number
then we would add the class of active
that would give it a border to the left
and increase the font weight so we need
to change this a bit because we're not
gonna we're not passing down these
values from parent to child component
it's all living in the same component
for now so we need to change these to be
named what you know what they ought to
be named so let's scroll up a bit and
check out our state and see what we've
named these this is a little bit
different than we usually do state
usually we don't use this constructor
but that's how we copied it over so
we'll just work with it as is right now
so it looks like
all right so we can do this state active
section we can do fatter positions so
you do this state active section and
then handle scroll
yeah I guess we'll do this handle scroll
let's go down here and we'll change this
to this state active section and let's
see what we're past was the past handle
scroll
scroll to item okay
roll into you
so we don't even have a scroll into view
they don't have that I'm assuming what's
supposed to happen is the handle scroll
oh well stroll into view is actually a a
separate component
as well
sorry I'm just trying to make sense of
this of where where this stuff is coming
from so we have the scroll interview but
I'm pretty sure this does not exist
anywhere else in our component no it
doesn't
let's see
that's why all right so this role
interview
we're not importing anywhere
we don't have it anywhere else in this
component and we're not actually I don't
know whistling uh so check this out
so in this other react project we're
using stroll in the view here but we're
not pulling it in anywhere and it
doesn't exist anywhere else so if we do
you know control fine you know we don't
get it so scroll I nto so it's just
there I'm I don't let's see let's do the
search in the whole repo for everywhere
we're using scroll in the view so we do
have a component name scrolling a view
two routes
oh wow okay so this then is a container
component Wow
okay you'll see
okay John Hanson says scrolling to view
is a native jazz command okay that makes
so much sense I did not know that sorry
to everybody who knew that and was
thinking like what are you talking about
okay that makes more sense it threw me
off that we had a component named this
as well but now that I look at it that
was capitalized so it definitely wasn't
the same thing anyway
so I wonder if this will work if we
leave it out I'm gonna leave it out for
now and just trying to continue on see
if we can get just like a working
something working here key is not
defined I thought we took key out did I
not save it
just a different spot let me give a
refresher and see keys not defined to 61
oh yeah cuz I'm still using key right
there if the state active section equals
I think I'm not gonna do I think when
you use title
let's let's see did we have resist state
active section
yes I'm not gonna put title I'm gonna
say does it spring scroll to item spring
okay that makes more sense now I'm gonna
put in another Li and we're just gonna
change this to summer you see we're hard
coding a lot of this probably end up
going back to something that's closer to
what we originally had but for now this
will just simplify things
oops and what this would be capitalized
okay
we need to probably do yeah we need to
say this touch scroll to item so we're
having that red squiggly line there this
stroke
okay all right let's see this prop set
header is just not a function okay where
we at then let's find set headers you're
right it's not it's gonna be this dot
set headers hey no error ah we got one
each is not defined you know what are we
I bet each is some sort of I better to
using like low - each or something like
that and that's where we're getting this
I'm check on my other screen this other
component and see what we're pulling in
where do we get this from handle scroll
know where we got handle
we got it from the the page
we did you know now that's it we did
pull and lo - each so let's let's bring
this in as here as well and we're gonna
have to go yarn ad couldn't find package
lo - each side now what is called
okay I think it's called low - for each
maybe
anybody that familiar with lodash
that's two you know what I can I think I
can probably see where we're getting
this from if I just check out the
package.json for this Resource Center
project so if you want to check out that
Resource Center project on github I
pasted the link a little bit earlier I'm
gonna paste it again for those of you
that have come in a bit later on so you
can search through this as well right
now I'm gonna look at this package JSON
file and see I'm hoping we didn't bring
in all of lodash
I don't see I don't see low - anywhere
how is this possible
we're definitely using low - and a lot
of components but Heisler - I'm your
score in force
I guess we have all of lodash being
imported
hmm
alright I'm not sure if for each will
work but it's worth a shot
so let's see now I still do that
who
I guess not all the pieces of lodash are
available in different modules
I wonder if I could just replace the
each with a normal for each
what is it
all right let me my timer went off so
let me do another five minutes and go
back to the live chat and then I'll come
back to this and figure out what's going
on so let me scroll to where I left off
last time
all right Frankie says just curious and
this may be trivial however is the text
going to be justified all right so we're
talking about well I can't see not
because I messed it up but that section
header and then the text in there so I
don't know I I haven't really thought
about the text in that particular
section maybe I'll have to mess around
with ways to align the text see which
which one looks the best
Frankie says that's totally cool feeding
the less affluent yeah it is I think
that is one of the really cool things
that the university does to you know
encourage students to take part in in a
lot of work like that especially and it
really reflects well on the students
that they're willing to give up you know
Spring Break that's more like a vacation
and a party and instead like use that
time to serve other people so that's
really cool I think they do a lot of
good there's gonna be a lot of great
content for that section of the website
you know great images videos and stories
so I think it's gonna end up being one
of like the really kind of the better
parts of this site once it's finished
Frankie was given advice on the the
heading and what to do with it and then
said but what do I know play around with
it you're the expert and I'm learning
I don't know I'm the expert and I
definitely value your opinion and your
contributions to the stream so I don't
know I see it is us helping each other
to get better so I mean I hope you can
learn from me but you know I don't want
anyone to think that that I'm somehow
you know the the expert at this you know
and we're all just trying to do good
work right and if we can help each other
then that's great because we'll end up
doing better work together then we could
separately so I always welcome questions
and I try my best to help but I also
really really appreciate when you all
help me even if it's just offering your
opinion about how something looks that's
really really helpful
I was talking about shaving my beard
earlier and I said that my wife hates
the beard and Franky agrees with my wife
all right so she'll be happy to hear
that I know I did on Instagram a while
back I did a poll and asking people if I
should shave my beard or not and it was
overwhelming that everyone wanted me to
keep the beard and I joke with my wife
and said like you should have recruited
people to vote shave it you know so off
to let her know there is somebody else
out there that thinks I'm better without
the beard
Frankie also said hopefully you'll feel
better soon thank you I appreciate that
I'm hoping to it's the doctor asked me
yesterday if I wanted an antibiotic
prescribed or not and I said yes I know
people worry about getting antibiotics
prescribed too much and I understand
that but I thought you know what I've
been sick for a week and I don't have I
got a busy week coming up I don't have
time to come back to the doctor I don't
want to mess with it I was worried I had
an ear infection too and it's like I
don't want to mess with that I already
couldn't hear out of one ear and I'm
like you know I don't want to mess with
that
I don't know if it could really happen
but have an infection necklace your
brain kind of freaks me out like I'm not
sure if an ear infection can get into
your brain but I don't want to I don't
want to find out you know so I thought
hey we'll just get it get it taken care
of you know what I'm gonna do my five
minutes timer went up but I'm gonna go
through and answer all the questions
right now and then I'm gonna see what
time it is and how tired I feel and
that'll determine whether or not I we
have time to finish this component we
might just do part two tomorrow and
finish the component then I kind of
think at this point if I just installed
all of lodash that would solve the
problem so we'll see maybe maybe I'll do
that but there may be other problems
right after that so I don't really know
if this is something that I can get
working in just a few minutes
they have a spam caller calling me right
now okay so let me keep going
rotate says use the bootstrap scrolls
fire or build your own yeah well we're
trying to build our own here the and
this I guess is partly my problem you
know how I like to do things I don't
like to prepare I like it to show you
like in reality what happens when I try
to do you know something at work so I
didn't take time beforehand to check out
that other repo and see and I didn't
remember how much work was involved in
making this happen
the last time so I underestimated the
amount of time it would take so I
assumed oh I could do this in one stream
but I think it's gonna have to be a two
stream thing so yeah so I guess at the
beginning the stream maybe I was a
little bit optimistic about how this
would go but I looking through this I
think there's some refactoring that
can't happen to do this a little bit
more simply so maybe we'll maybe we'll
get into that tomorrow but I always like
to make something work first before I
worry about refactoring you know cuz
that's the most important part like the
user doesn't care what your code looks
like you want to get it to work at some
point you definitely want it to look
good and if you have time to do both
then definitely do both but I'm trying
to keep the user in mind first and then
you know I always you know can go back
later and do it I don't always do it but
I could
all right so Adrienne has a question how
to find an internship with only basics
of react what website should I look at
you know what I don't really know of any
websites for internships does anyone
know of any internship websites I know
there are definitely good internships
out there and some of the bigger tech
companies actually pay really well for
interns I've I've seen some things
online they claim that interns at you
know Facebook in Google actually make
more than I do which is pretty cool
but I'm I don't know where those are
listed at I mean probably somewhere on
the sites for those companies but it'd
be nicer if you go to one place and find
everything listed from lots of different
companies unfortunately I don't I don't
know of a site like that if anybody
knows something like that please put it
in the in the live chat Frankie did say
be proactive send your email out or go
directly to the companies that's that's
definitely good advice Frankie's been
emailing all day that's all that's the
way to do it Frankie it's I mean you got
to be proactive about that okay dawn
Saviour says that this is actually a
good time for streaming right after
dinner
okay cool
dexter of world says what's the name of
the color scheme what is it
SETI that's it SETI
that's my assuming you're asking about
my visual studio codes game so it's the
SETI 4 for the text and for the UI
alright John Hanson says could handle
scroll just keep track of on change
values of scroll why John says sorry not
much experience on my part with low -
alright let's let's check it out let's
see handle scroll could handle scroll
just keep track of change
heeey
you know there's got to be a better way
we can do this right oh my thing sorry I
said I was gonna get through the live
chat first let me I must stop myself
let's get to the live set first let's
see oh it looks like something happened
with the stream because we drops yeah we
dropped a lot of users
I mean it's entirely possible that most
you just got bored with me but it it
looks like I missed it but something
happened and the stream data was like
terrible for a second and then it got
better so I apologize if the stream cut
out see
all right let me know if if you all can
see yeah actually I see the point where
everything just just totally dropped off
all right so I didn't notice that at the
time yeah let me know if if y'all can
see and hear me right now I'm down to
the last question in the chat kuden de
Nanji says hey Jesse nice to see you're
back I missed these sessions they
actually helped me in my last term's
computer science project awesome I'm
really glad that they were they were
helpful to you yeah definitely I'm back
I want to try to stream more regularly
now and so I've taken some steps to make
that happen more so I've got the new
webcam and I think it'll make it easier
for me to stream at home because the I
was just worried about the quality of
streaming with a laptop in my lab of it
kind of shaking and getting people
motion sick so um hopefully I can I can
be back and I would like last week I
just wasn't feeling well what I don't
feel I don't exercise I feel more
depressed I just don't feel like doing
much so that's also a part of the reason
why I wasn't streaming so much last week
so I'm gonna do my best to keep up with
my health my exercise and my mental
health so that I can keep doing streams
for you oh and do good quality streams
[Music]
alright so I'm at the bottom of the chat
it looks like I'm still not sure about
the video quality I didn't I didn't get
any response and if in terms of if y'all
can can see and hear me anymore and
we're still at a low count for viewers
so I'm gonna I'm gonna be on the safe
side and assume that there is something
going on with the stream and so I'm
gonna stop working on this right now
Oh we'll probably commit what we have
here
so that you all can check it out if you
want even though it's not working and
then we'll pick up with this sometime
tomorrow
and hopefully get it working then so
let's just let me just commit this now
so I don't forget this we're gonna do a
git status we're gonna see what what we
have here lots of stuff and then we'll
do a git add we'll add everything and
let's do yarn you're in cm and we're
gonna do feature and let's say functions
and markup for squirrels by nav to
submission page actually now I think
about it I probably shouldn't have
changed it I shouldn't have said mission
page because I think we have a mission
page for mission statement oh it just
happened oh it's not gonna let me use
this raps on all right so let me let me
get rid of some of these I'm just gonna
comment some stuff out here that's
giving us airs right now actually let's
just comment out a lot of what what we
just added because
really it doesn't work I just want it to
be in there so I can you know have it
available for me to load on my laptop
let's grab yeah I'm assuming this
section it's not gonna work
whoops
normally I do not recommend just
commenting this much code out but I do I
want this committed just don't have time
right now to make it work because I'm
most likely gonna be working from home
tomorrow on a different machine okay all
right okay cool so we brought this back
no airs this time let's go let's go with
the yarn cm and then we'll give it a
retry flag so we won't have to type
everything in again no lies and making
me type it in again did I need two flags
all right there we go no still have more
errors on throttle is defined but never
news like throttle slice headers in each
okay
hopefully this goes a little better
all right there's unit test went pretty
quickly that's good news and then tests
yes all right wonderful push this and
this might have been a better idea to do
on a on a branch it's on a side branch
instead of master oh well okay okay
Frankie just said cool so it looks like
something's still working all right so a
lot of stuffs been commented out but
it's all available on github so you can
check it out if you want to if anybody
wants to take a shot at trying to make
some of this work feel free do not feel
obligated to do anything but if you're
interested you know a pull requests are
always welcome and we're gonna tackle
this tomorrow I'll tell you what at this
point I'm trying to decide between make
what we have work or just completely
redo it from scratch I'm not sure what I
want to do I this is kind of a problem
that I think would be really cool to try
to do from scratch especially on a
stream and figure it out I don't know
but realistically like is it worth it
for that time I'm not sure what would
take longer at this point so it's
possible that might happen but for now
it's after 6:00 p.m. where I'm at I bet
my wife's wondering where I am so I'm
gonna go thank you all so much for
watching I'm really sorry about whatever
happened in the stream when everything
dropped off thanks for those of you that
hung in there thank you thanks for all
the advice I will do my best to be back
for a stream tomorrow until then have a
wonderful day